I was acting in a movie in Vegas and it  just turned out that uh during that time  Scorsese was doing casino and I'd never  really met Martin Scorsese before and so  I got an invite to go visit uh the set  of Casino yeah this is my yeah this like  right up there with you know the gates  of Oz opening up and I'm gonna meet the  wizard so I'm walking to meet the wizard  I'm walking on the set they kind of see  me and then Don Rickles goes Quentin  thank God you're here this guy doesn't  know what he's doing at all thank God a  real director has finally showed up this  cat is out of it please say this is a  disaster it's a disaster please save us  from this wreckage you are a talented  man we need your talent oh my God okay  now Marty's laughing the crew is  laughing De Niro's let me I wanna hide  under the carpet yeah of course so funny  ah